みなさんこれ知ってますか？
これじゃないやつも見たことあると思うんですけども
これはですね、防犯ブザーというやつでございます
♪prrrrr
あ、やばいこれ、なんか、すごい、やばい、やばい
あぁ～
ｳｳﾞｪｴ↑
あの、小さい子供とか持ってるかもしれないんですけども
痴漢とか、ストーカーとかね
不審者とか
そーゆー人に追われてちょっと危険なときにですよ
誰も周りにいない、と
助けてくれる人が誰もいないときに
これを引っぱればでかい音が鳴るので
それを聞いた人が助けに来てくれるというものでございます
防犯ブザー
あんまりね、こうゆうのは家で鳴らすものじゃないんですよ
で、この防犯ブザーなんですけども、
俺は思ってしまった。
ここを抜くともう音が鳴るんですよ。
ここ、ここね。
♪ＰＲＲ...
あっ、待っ、待っｔ、ﾌﾞﾙﾌﾞﾙﾌﾞﾙﾌﾞﾙﾌﾞr
抜くとすぐに音がなっちゃうんですけども、
そのあと止めるのが難しい。
例えば今、これ抜いてなげますよ？
♪PRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRR
って感じでね。
あの、
音がめちゃくちゃでかいんですよ。
戻すのに時間がかかるから
仮に間違えて抜いちゃったとしたら
それ直すのにすっごい大変なんすよ。
うるさいんですよ！
ずっとピピピピピピピって鳴ってるから
もう大迷惑なんですよ！
止めないと音が止まんないっていう危険性も兼ね備えた
一歩間違えれば凶器になってしまう、
そういう危険なものなんです。（？）
そこで俺は考えた。
今回ですね、この防犯ブザーなんですけれども、
この穴を挿す、以外の方法で止めれれば
一番いいのかな、と思いまして、
今回僕、何個か作戦を考えてみました。
防犯ブザーをこの正規の方法以外の方法で止める方法を
ちょっと調べていこうと思います！
実際にちょっと一個ずつやっていきましょう！
水っていうのはね、音が伝わりにくいんですよ
もうこれをポチャンと入れるだけで、
ひょっとしたらもう音がなくなるかも…
ﾎﾟﾁｬﾝ
もう一個あるんだよ
もう一個あるんだよ！
そういうときもあると思ってもう一個準備したヨ！
うん。（迫真）
これ水に入れても
♪ﾌﾟｷﾞｬｱｱｱｱｱｱｧｧｧｧｧｧ（壊れかけ）
ふふっ
もう…
死にそうじゃん
これじゃあ誰も助けに来ないよ
♪ﾋﾟｷﾞｬｱｱｱｧｧｧｧｧｧｧ
意外と水きくな。
音出した状態で入れてみましょう
では行きます。
スリー、トゥー、ワン
♪PRRRRRRRRRRR
♪Prr..prr...prrrr
お、お、お、お、効いてる効いてる、効いてるよ
♪（かすかな音）
お、効いてる効いてる！
出してみます。
♪brrrr...rrrrrr..rrrrrrr...(壊れかけ)
水はききますねぇ
♪ｷﾞｲｲｲｨｨｨｨｨｨ
♪ｶﾞｱｱｱｱｧｧｧｧｧ
なんかセミとかカエルとか、
これすごいな
たくさん入れてみたら、音楽隊になるのかもしれない
けっこう買ったんでちょっ全部入れてみましょう
♪PPPPPPPPPPP
♪ｼﾞｼﾞｼﾞｼﾞｼﾞｼﾞｼﾞｼﾞｼﾞｼﾞｼﾞｼﾞ（コオロギみたいな音）
♪ｷｭｲﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟｷｭｲﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟｷｭｲｷｭｷｭｷｭ…ｨ…
ｨ…
死んだな。
では次行こう！
（これは）金属でできてるわけですよ
金属類とか機械類っていうのはやっぱ熱に弱いんで
もう熱してみたらワンパンかも知れないですね！
大丈夫だよな、
すぐ逝けよ！
スリー、ツー、ワン
♪PRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRR
うわわわ、うわわ、
♪～
はやくはやく
（なお鳴り響く防犯ブザー）
しーしーしー
はやく、はやく！はやく!!
まってこれやばいじゃん、爆発する？
怖い、ばくは、爆発しそう
だいじょぶかなぁ？
電子レンジ「PPPPPPP」
（中を確認）
ムリィ！
つぎ
水とか炎とかっていうのはね、すぐに準備できないんで、
まあ、手っ取り早く工具を使いましょう
ドライバーで開けれそうな部分があるんで
あのね、あの、
これ、でもさ、これ早く止めないとダメなんだよねー
音が鳴ってからドライバーですぐにあけて
すぐ止めたれらまぁオッケー
時間がかかるようだったら使えないっすねー
レディー？
ゴー！
♪PRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRR
はやく、はやく！
♪PRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRR
あーあーあっあっ
♪PRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRR
あっ止まった
は、余裕じゃん！
これ早くね？
これ有効だなぁ！
ドライバーあり！
もうあけてあけてプツンで一発でした
イヤッホォォ！
♪PRRRRRR
ｶﾞﾝｯ
ｶﾗｶﾗ…
FIN（♪エンディングテーマ）
【字幕編集者よりお知らせ】
一緒にはじめしゃちょーの動画に字幕を付けてみよう！
右下の歯車マーク→「字幕」→「字幕を追加」から！
ルールを守って動画を面白くしよう！